el barsa informó obstáculos económicos
para que messi dejará el equipo cuáles
pueden haber sido los motivos que llevan
al astro bis a vincularse al parís saint
germain
gracias por comunicarse bueno el parís
saint germain tiene un proyecto
deportivo muy ambicioso que era lo que
estaba buscando tiene jugadores con los
que tiene mucha afinidad como como
neymar como di maría como paredes
solistas argentinos y claramente messi
al no poder seguir vinculado barcelona
busca un proyecto ganador y creo que el
equipo francés más allá de toda la
capacidad económica que es evidente que
tiene le le ofrece un proyecto muy
ambicioso desde lo deportivo no el psg
es un equipo con numerosas estrellas
como ahora pochettino para conformar un
verdadero grupo para trabajar pues en
medio de todo con los egos de los
jugadores
ese es el gran reto para el entrenador
pochettino tiene que
que intentar
manejar el vestuario de la mejor manera
posible y creo que hoy en día los
entrenadores del primer mundo de los los
equipos más poderosos tienen en el
manejo del vestuario el gran reto cuando
lo logran hacer como louis sociedad en
real madrid por ejemplo lo hace
guardiola lo logró algo en barcelona y
terminan generando equipos muy exitosos
messi al ser argentino igual que
pochettino seguramente será uno de los
que más lo ayudará en ese sentido a
tratar de que el vestuario tenga la
mayor armonía posible lo que también es
real es que a estas alturas de la
carrera de messi para cualquier
futbolista es una ilusión enorme jugar
al lado de él jugar el mejor al lado el
mejor jugador del mundo y uno de los
mejores de la historia entonces el
problema no va a hacerme si a lo mejor
serán los demás y cómo se adaptan a él y
como pochettino logra satisfacer todos
esos egos que usted bien mencionado no
bueno con esta salida del barça quien
pierde más messi o el barça
no claramente el barça claramente el
barça el barça
increíblemente deja ir libre a al mejor
jugador que ha tenido en toda su
historia
no recibe un dólar por esto y se ve
disminuido
tremendamente desde lo deportivo no deja
de ser un una potencia después el fútbol
nos puede dar sorpresas y puede darse
que el barça termine haciendo un muy
buen equipo el fútbol pero pero lograr
eso sin mes y siempre será más difícil
dime si tiene un reto por delante que lo
va lo va a poner seguramente en lo más
alto del fútbol europeo inmediatamente
no